I've always been interested in this
question of survival past death uh and
so it just naturally evolved my
publisher came back to me and said do
you want to write about something else
right at the moment where I was thinking
about I wanted to write about that and
so it was just this
synchronicity really and I I jumped into
that book
with some awareness of what I was going
to write about but it was really a
journey for me in the way that the UFO
book wasn't because it it there I didn't
know where that book was going to go I I
knew the topics of research that I
wanted to cover but I learned a lot as I
went along and I also lost my younger
brother during the process of writing
the book and so it became a more
personal Journey for me because I was I
I for instance one of the things I
covered in the book was mediumship
which does
um and you know most people think it's
completely bogus you're just talking
about people in you know have a sign in
their window saying they can come in and
they have a crystal ball or something
like that it's not like that there's
some very skilled individuals out there
who can access information that appears
to be coming from a deceased person and
so I had some profound experiences with
some mediums in which my brother and my
friend Bud Hopkins who I had actually
been with when he died in in 2011 both
seem to be communicating to me through
this medium
so
um how do you separate that from cold
reading is like the natural question
that would come up yeah I mean my point
is it just became a personal Journey for
me intermingled with a lot of solid
research
um and a cold reading is very very
different because
that's usually when you're physically
with the person so and these these
readings I had I was not one of them was
on the phone I couldn't even see it the
person couldn't even see me and the
second one was on Skype she didn't know
anything about me she just saw me
sitting in a room with a blank wall but
a cold reading it's a way of
manipulation so like they'll get
information from somebody in the room
and then they'll come they'll assume
certain things they'll come back with
other questions to kind of um trick
people into certain kinds of answers I
mean I wrote about it in my book I don't
remember you know all the details it's
it's just a way of kind of creating a
phony perception
that there is this the said dead person
there and the thing about a cold reading
is it's not it doesn't have the kind of
specific information
that I was talking about in the readings
that I had where
just endless specific very very specific
information is delivered that this
medium couldn't possibly know that I'm
not revealing hints about in any way
and it's also the personality of the
cease person comes through you know and
none of these things happen with a cold
reading they're they're just much more
vague
um and it's just another order
you know of experience I mean there's no
there's no comparison and that's just
one
media I mean you know you want to know
what the best evidence is for survival
after death and I I don't think it's
something we can prove
but there are so many areas to draw from
um and you know I actually went through
and said you know one of them is young
children who remember past lives very
young children
and
investigators are able to verify their
Memories by locating the actual person
that they said they were because they
provide enough details to be able to do
that and this is you're talking two and
three-year-olds who didn't you know have
never been exposed to anything related
to that previous person with all kinds
of emotional reactivity and sometimes
knowledge of of skills that that
previous person had that a
three-year-old would never otherwise
know you know a lot of things like this
very interesting and compelling cases
that were studied by researchers at the
University of Virginia for a long time
and then you have these near-death
experiences which I think people know
about where you go into you know you
apparently uh don't have any
you're not you're basically clinically
dead when these things happen and you
leave your body and you go off into this
afterlife realm and you come back and
people's lives are forever to change
because of that um and there are certain
characteristics of those experiences
that are consistent
throughout the world and those have been
studied by many scientists medical
doctors
um you know and I these are the people I
drew from in my book to really get to
the bottom of what those experiences are
about
and then there's things that happen to
people at the very end of life when
they're dying that seem to be
Communications with the other side you
know if there's investigators in UK that
have studied these cases and there's
then there's mediumship and there's both
mental and physical mediumship they're
two different things after death
Communications I'm sure a lot of people
have experienced that where you
you've lost someone you love and you're
probably grieving when these things
happen and you you you you sense you
have some kind of experience where you
feel that you are getting a
communication from that person you don't
need a medium for that you can get a
direct communication it can come in many
forms
and it's absolutely unprovable it's
totally subjective
but um there's a sense of knowing when
something like that happens and it's
very meaningful to the person receiving
it and I bet a lot of the listeners
right now have had those kinds of
experiences and most people don't talk
about them or they do just among their
family members or their close friends
but it's it's very I had a number of
these events happen to me when I lost my
brother and it's just very very in some
ways more compelling evidence for an
individual than any of the research
could ever be because it's it's your own
experience of something
so that's another and those have also
been studied there have been statistical
studies on them and all kinds of studies
by psychologists people like that
yeah and then there's apparitions that
are actually interactive I'm not just
talking about you see a ghost somewhere
but I'm talking about
something that appears to be conscious
that doesn't have a body that's actually
responsive to uh a human the action of a
human being like if you wave to it it
waves back something like that which you
know seeing this ghostly forum and it it
responds to you and that suggests that
there's an actual Consciousness there or
and then you can pick up there's one
case in my book where you're able
actually this this young boy was able to
actually pick up messages from that
entity which was in their house and
everybody in the family was seeing it
and the entity revealed enough
information about herself
that they were relatable able to confirm
that she was the person who had
previously lived in the house and nobody
knew anything about her when they moved
in
so you know that's a very strong case of
an apparition that's evidential it's not
just the same as somebody saying oh I
was in a haunted house and I saw a ghost
you know there's there's a really a high
level way you can study
the best of the best when it comes to
evidence for these kinds of things and
that's what I tried to bring together in
my book called surviving death a
journalist investigates evidence for an
afterlife which came out in 2017 and
there was a series on Netflix with the
same title it's actually there now it
came out in
2021 I think
um it's a six-part series on Netflix
called surviving death which also covers
a lot of this stuff and I think people
might enjoy seeing that so yeah so in my
book I tried to bring together the the
best evidence from all these different
areas and kind of consolidate them into
one volume where you really only have to
look at this if you want to get a sense
of what's being done in all these very
areas of research and also read direct
testimonies of people who have had
near-death experiences people have
studied meat studied mediums a lot of
people wrote their own chapters in my
book just like they did for my UFO book
so
anyway I just think there's a lot of
compelling evidence but it's not
provable because you know when you're
dead you're not
unless you can die and come back some
way that you can actually prove it which
we can't do but it's just suggestive and
it's fascinating to ponder and think
about I mean it depends on what your
personal definition is a proof right
some people feel that if they've just
had a certain kind of a dream of someone
or they've felt like they've had a
communication from someone that's enough
for them
you know but in terms of scientific
level proof I don't we don't have that
when people encounter UFOs and they
develop some of these extraordinary
psychic abilities is that related to The
Hitchhiker effect
it could be I don't know it could be I
don't think always though
and I don't know I don't know if people
who have had the hitchhiker effect have
developed these these other abilities
I'm I actually actually don't know
um maybe they